where we left off after the mitosis
videos is that we had two gametes we had
a sperm and an egg let me draw the sperm
so you had the sperm and then you had an
egg I mean we'll do an egg in a
different color that's the egg and we
all know how this story goes the sperm
fertilizes the egg and all a whole
cascade of events start occurring the
the walls of the egg then become
impervious to other sperm so that only
one sperm can get in but that's not the
focus of this video the focus of this
video is how this fertilized egg
develops once it has become a zygote so
after its fertilized you're now so we
remember from the meiosis videos that
each of these were haploid haploid or
that they had I added an extra I there
or that or that they had half the
contingency of the DNA haploid as soon
as the sperm fertilizes this egg now all
of a sudden you have a diploid zygote
let me do that so now let me pick a nice
color so now you're going to have a
diploid zygote that's going to have 2n a
2n complement of the DNA material or you
can or kind of the full complement of
what a normal cell in our human body
would have so this is diploid and it's a
zygote which is just enough fancy way of
saying the fertilized egg and it's now
ready to essentially turn into an
organism so immediately after
fertilization the zygote starts
experiencing cleavage and that's well
it's experiencing mitosis that's the
mechanism but it doesn't increase a lot
in size so just you know this one right
here will then turn into it'll just
split up via mitosis into two like that
and of course these are each 2n and then
those are going to split into four like
that and each of these are all have the
the same exact genetic complement as
that first zygote and it keeps splitting
and this this
this mass of cells we can start calling
it this right here this is referred to
as the more EULA more EULA and it
actually comes from the word for
mulberry because it looks like a
mulberry selection let me just kind of
simplify things a little bit because we
have to start here so we start with a
zygote so I go this is a fertilized egg
it just starts duplicating via mitosis
and you end up with a with a ball of
cells it's often not going to be a power
of two because these cells at least in
the initial stages are all duplicating
it all at once and then you have this
more ela
more ela now once the more ela gets to
about 16 cells or so and we're talking
about four or five days this isn't an
exact process they start differentiating
differentiating a little bit where the
outer cells and this kind of turns into
a sphere let me make it a little bit
more sphere like so you had it starts
differentiating between let me make some
outer cells and this would be a
cross-section of it it's really going to
be look more like a sphere that's the
outer cells and then you have your inner
cells on the inside these outer cells
these outer cells are going to be called
or are called the trophoblast different
color tro fo trophoblast let me scroll
over now I go there and then the inner
cells and this is kind of the crux of
what this video is all about let me
scroll down a little bit the inner cells
look at suitable color the inner cells
right there are called the embryo blast
embryo blast and then what's going to
happen is some fluid is going to start
filling in some of this gap between the
embryo blast and the trophoblast so
you're going to start having some fluid
that comes in there and so this the
Moorilla will eventually look like this
where the trophoblast or the outer
membrane is kind of this huge sphere of
cells and this is all happening as
keep replicating mitosis is the
mechanism so now my trophoblast is going
to look like that and then my embryo
blast is going to look like this
sometimes the embryo blasts oh let me so
this is the embryo blast embryo blast
sometimes it's also called the inner
cell mass so let me write that inner
inner cell mass and this is what's going
to turn into the organism and so just
just so you know a couple of the labels
that are involved here if we're dealing
with a mammalian organism and we are
mammals we call this thing that the
Moorilla turned into as a zygote then
amarilla then the cells of the maurella
started to differentiate into the
trophoblast we're kind of the outside
cells and then the embryo blasts and
then you have this the space that forms
here and this is just fluid fluid it's
called the Blastoise seal blasto seal a
very non-intuitive spelling of the seal
part of blasto seal but once this is
formed this is called a blastocyst
that's the entire thing right here let
me scroll down a little bit this whole
thing is called the blastocyst and this
is the case in humans in humans now it
can be a very confusing topic because a
lot of times in a lot of books on
biology you'll say hey you go from the
Moorilla to the blast chiller the blast
o spear stage let me write those words
down so you know sometimes we'll say
maurella and you go to blastula blastula
and sometimes it's called blast o fear
blast o spear and I want to make it very
clear that these are essentially the
same stages in development these are
just four but you know in a lot of books
they'll start talking about you know
frogs or tadpoles or things like that
and this applies to them while we're
talking about mammals especially the
ones that are closely related
the stage is the blastocyst stage and
the real differentiator is when people
talk about just blastula and blast those
fears there isn't necessarily this
differentiation between this these
outermost cells and these these
embryonic or this embryo blast or this
inner inner cell mass here but since
this the focus of this video is humans
and really that's where I wanted to
start from because that's what we are
and that's what's interesting we're
going to focus on the blastocyst now
everything I've talked about in this
video it was really to get to this point
because what we have here these little
green cells that I drew right here in
the blastocyst this inner cell mass this
is what will turn into the organism and
you say okay Sal if that's the organism
what's all of this what's all of this
these purple cells out here this this
trophoblast out there that is going to
turn into the placenta and I'll do a
future video where in a human it'll turn
into a placenta so let me write that
down it'll turn into the placenta I'll
do a whole future video about I guess
how babies are born and I could learn a
ton about that this past year because I
a baby was born in our house but the
placenta is really kind of what the what
the embryo develops inside of and it's
it's the interface between especially in
humans and in mammals between the
developing fetus and its mother so it
kind of is the exchange mechanism that
that separates their two systems but
allows the necessary functions to go on
between them but that's not the focus of
this video the focus of this video is
the fact that these cells which at this
point are they've differentiated
themselves away from the placenta cells
but they still haven't decided what
they're going to become you know maybe
this cell and it's it's descendants may
eventually start becoming part of the
nervous system while these cells right
here might become muscle tissue while
these cells right here might I don't
know might become might become the liver
these cells right here are called
embryonic stem cells and probably the
first time in this video you're hearing
a term that you might recognize so if I
were to just take one of these cells and
actually just to introduce you another
as soon as as soon as we you know we
have this zygote here as soon as it
starts dividing each of these cells are
called a blast omere and you're probably
wondering Sal why does this word blast
keep appearing in this in this kind of
embryology videos this you know these
development videos and that comes from
it comes from the Greek for Spore
Blastoise so you know it's just as the
organism is beginning to Spore or out or
grow but I won't go into the the word
origins of it but that's where it comes
from and that's why everything has this
blast in it so these are blastomeres so
when I talk about embryonic stem cells
I'm talking about the individual
blastomeres
inside of this embryo blast or inside of
this inner cell mass these words are
actually unusually fun to say so each of
these is an embryonic stem cell let me
write this down and in a vibrant color
because this is a so each of these right
here
our embryonic stem cells and I wanted to
get to this in embryonic stem cells and
the reason why these are interesting and
I think you already know is that there's
a huge debate around these one these
have the potential to turn into anything
that they have this this plasticity
that's another word that you might hear
let me write that down to plasticity and
the word essentially comes from you know
like a plastic can turn into anything
else when some when we sit when we say
that something has plasticity we're
talking about its potential to turn into
a lot of different things so the theory
is and there's already some trials that
seem to substantiate this especially in
some lower organisms that look if you
have some damage at some point in your
body if you have some damage let's let
me draw a nerve cell let me say I have a
you know I won't go into the the actual
mechanics of a nerve cell but let's say
that we have some damage at some point
on a nerve cell right there and because
of that you know someone is paralyzed or
there's some nerve too strong function
we're dealing with multiple sclerosis or
who knows what the idea is is look we
have these cells here that could turn
into anything we could that could turn
to anything as you know and we're just
really understanding how it knows what
to turn into it really has to look at
its environment say hey what's what are
the guys around me doing and maybe
that's what helps dictate what it does
but the idea is you take these things
that could turn into anything and you
put them where the damage is so you
start you layer and where the damage is
and then they can turn into the cell
that they need to turn into so they were
in this case they would turn into nerve
cells they would turn into nerve cells
and repair the damage and you know maybe
a cure the paralysis for that individual
so there's it's a huge exciting area of
research and you could even in theory
grow new organs if someone needs a
kidney transplant or a heart transplant
maybe in the future we could take a
colony of these embryonic stem cells
maybe we can put them in some type of
other creature or who knows what and we
can turn it into a replacement heart or
replacement kidney so there's a huge a
huge amount of excitement about what
these can do I mean they could cure a
lot of formerly uncurable diseases or
provide you know hope for a lot of
patients who might otherwise die but
obviously there's a debate here and the
debate all revolves around the issue of
when if you were to go in here and try
to extract one of these cells you're
going to kill this embryo you're going
to kill this developing embryo and that
developing embryo had the potential to
become a human being so you know and
I'll put it it it's it's a potential it
obviously has to be in the right
environment and it has to you know have
a willing mother and and and all of the
rest but it does have the potential and
so for if you if for those especially I
think in the pro-life camp who say hey
you know this is this anything that has
a potential be a human being that's
that's that is life and it should not be
killed so people on the on that side of
the camp they they're against you know
the destroying of this embryo and and
I'm not making this video to takes
either sides of that argument but you
know it's a potential to turn into a
human being it's a potential right so
obviously there's a huge amount of
debate but now now you know in this
video what people are talking about when
they say embryonic stem cells well and
obviously the next question is say hey
well why don't they just call them stem
cells as opposed to end
Briona stem cells and that's because in
in all of our bodies you do have what
are called somatic stem cells let me
write that down
so matic or adult stem cells and we all
have them there in our bone marrow to
help produce red blood cells other parts
of our body but the problem with somatic
stem cells is they're not as plastic so
not as plastic which means that they
can't form any type of cell in the human
body there's an area of research where
people actually may be trying to make
them more plastic and if they are they
are able to take these somatic stem
cells and make them more plastic it
might might maybe kill the need to have
these embryonic stem cells although if
they may be if they do this too good
maybe these will have the potential to
turn into human beings as well so that
could become a debatable issue but right
now this isn't an area of debate because
left to their own devices a somatic stem
cell or a adult stem cell won't turn
into a human being while an embryonic
one if it is implanted in a in a willing
mother then of course it will turn into
a human being and I want to make one
side note here because I don't want to
take any sides on the debate of you know
of well I mean the facts are facts this
does have the potential to turn to a
human being but it also has the
potential to save millions of lives
those both of those statements are facts
and then you can decide on your own
which side of that argument you'd like
to or what side of that balance you
would like to kind of put your own
opinion on but there's one thing I want
to talk about that's that in the public
debate is never brought up so you know
you have this notion of when you want to
get an embryonic stem cell line and when
when I say a stem cell line I mean you
take a couple of stem cells or let's say
you take one stem cell and then you put
it in a petri dish and then you allow it
to just duplicate so this one turns into
two those two turn into four then
someone could take one of these and then
put it in their own petri dish these are
a stem cell line they all came from one
unique embryonic stem cell or what what
initially was a blastomeres so that's
what they call about a stem cell line so
the debate obviously is when you start a
embryonic stem cell line you are
destroying an embryo
but I want to make the point here that
their embryos are being destroyed and in
other processes and namely in vitro
fertilization in vitro fertilization and
maybe this will be my next video
fertilization and this is just the
notion that they take a set of eggs out
of a mother is usually a couple that's
having trouble having a child and they
take a bunch of eggs out of the mother
so let's say they take maybe ten to
thirty eggs out of out of the mother
they actually perform a surgery take
them take them out of the ovaries of the
mother and then they fertilize them with
with with semen either it might come
from the father or a sperm donor so then
all of these become zygotes once they're
fertilized with semen so these all
become zygotes and then they allow them
to develop and they usually allow them
to develop to the blastocyst stage so
eventually these all of these turn into
blastocyst they have a blasto seal in
the center which is that which is that
this area of fluid they have of course
they have of course the embryo the inner
cell mass in them and what they do is
they look at the ones that they deem or
healthier or maybe you know the ones
that are at least just not unhealthy and
they'll take a couple of these and
they'll implant these into the mother so
all of this is occurring in a petri dish
so maybe these before look good so
they're going to take these four and
they're going to implant these into a
mother and if all goes well maybe one of
these will turn into will give the
couple a child so this one will develop
and maybe the other ones won't but you
know if you've seen John and eight John
and Kate Plus eight you know that many
times they implant a lot of them in
there just to increase the probability
that you get at least one child but
every now and then they implant seven or
eight and then you end up with eight
kids and that's why in vitro
fertilization often results in kind of
these you know multiple births and or
reality television shows on cable but
what do they do with all of these other
perfectly well I won't say perfectly
viable but these are embryos they may or
may not be perfectly viable but you know
you have the
embryos that have the potential just
like just like this one right here these
all have the potential to turn into a
human being but most fertility clinics
they roughly half of them they either
throw these away they destroy them they
allow them to die a lot of these are
frozen but just the process of freezing
them kills them and then bonding them
kills them again so most of these most
of these the process of in vitro
fertilization for every one child that
has a potential to develop into a
full-fledged human being you're actually
destroying tens of very viable embryos
so at least my take on it is if you're
against and I generally don't want to
take a side on this but if you are
against in if you are against and you
know research that involves embryonic
stem cells embryonic stem cells because
of the destruction of embryos on that
same I guess
philosophical ground you should also be
against in vitro fertilization in vitro
fertilization because both of these are
involved the destruction of zygotes I
think no i won't i won't talk more about
this because i really don't want to take
sides but i want to show that there is
kind of a an equivalence here that's
completely lost in this debate on
whether embryonic stem cells should be
used because they have a destruction of
embryos because you're destroying just
as many embryos in this well I won't say
just as many but you are destroying
embryos there's hundreds of thousands of
embryos that get destroyed and get
frozen and obviously destroyed in that
process as well through this in vitro
fertilization process so anyway now
hopefully you have the tools to kind of
engage in the debate around stem cells
and you see that it all comes from what
we learned about you know meiosis they
provoke paper they produce these these
these gametes the one the male gamete
fertilizes a female gamete the zygote
happens or gets created and start
splitting up the more eula and then it
turns in and then it keeps splitting and
it differentiates into the blastocyst
and then this is where the stem cells
are so you already know enough science
to engage in kind of a ver
a heated debate